so what actually is the ketogenic diet
let's cover that I'm gonna start simple
and then go a little bit more complex
but keep it simple overall it is simply
a method of eating certain foods and
certain combinations that cause the body
to run on ketones when you burn fat your
body makes ketones and ketones can be
used as an alternative fuel source in
fact your body loves running on ketones
it's actually a much healthier fuel
source there's less waste it's more
efficient there's more energy in ketones
and your body has a lot more stored fat
than it does stored sugar an average
person who's not overweight has roughly
between ninety and a hundred thousand
calories of stored fat versus that same
person only has about 1,700 calories of
stored sugar so what makes more sense
running your body on a hundred thousand
calories of stored energy or this small
reserve right here if you rely only on
sugar fuel or stored sugars called
glycogen when you start burning fat and
you get into fat burning you can go a
lot longer without being hungry and
especially without craving carbs so the
real big advantage of the ketogenic diet
versus other diets is that your hunger
goes away and your cravings go away
making it very very easy to do this
long-term so if we compare the ketogenic
diet to a low calorie diet or a low fat
diet both of these diets are a high
carbohydrate diet
it's the carbohydrates that actually
prevent fat burning so when someone does
a low calorie diet or a low fat diet yet
it's a high carbohydrate diet they are
gonna struggle they're gonna be
dependent on doing more exercise they
lose some temporary water weight but
they're gonna pretty much give up and
this is basically why 98% of diets fail
simply because they're not sustainable
why because you're hungry all the time
and you're craving carbs all the time
making it actually impossible to stick
to because of all the temptations you
have around you constantly so what makes
a person go in the keto
or basically making ketones is lowering
your carbohydrates you need to lower
your carbohydrates between 20 and 50
grams the lower the carbohydrate the
more you get into ketosis so really you
can look at the ketogenic diet as a fat
burning diet now if you're gonna lose
weight wouldn't you want to burn fat so
basically to make it really simple you
lower your carbohydrates you don't do a
high protein diet it's a moderate
protein diet so here's a little point
that people have a confusion on they
have this idea that the higher fat is
really bad for them but if you keep your
carbs low there is no danger in
consuming more fats so when you go into
ketosis you're simply shifting your fuel
source from the sugar to the fat and
this takes three days and the way to get
into this is to lower your carbs because
then it forces your body to look at
other sources of energy this stuff right
here stored fat alright let's go to the
next section all right so let's discuss
the ketogenic diet versus other diets so
you're gonna lose water weight for about
I don't know one to two weeks so it's
gonna give you a little sense of hope
that wow it's working I'm losing some
weight but its water weight
why would someone only lose water weight
and plateau within two weeks simply
because you've never gotten into fat
burning okay there's a big difference
with weight loss between losing water
and losing actual fat and realize that
exercise only contributes to only 15% of
your results so if in your mind if
you're thinking that I'm gonna exercise
this weight off its it going to be very
very insignificant compared to using a
correct diet with these other diets
you're going to be craving all the time
you're going to be hungry all the time
making it impossible to stick to for any
period of time so you end up failing
like 98% of people fail and it's always
blamed on the person's willpower but
think about it how are you gonna stick
to anything if you're craving and you're
hungry all the time it's actually going
to be impossible and as soon as you
consume too many carbs on these diets
you
lecher is going to come down because
you're gonna spike insulin insulin
suppresses the blood sugars and then
you're gonna put low blood sugars so
that's when you're cranky irritated on
this diet hungry all the time that's
what's really happening on the other
hand if you're gonna do a healthy
version of a keto plan we call it
healthy ketosis you're gonna actually
burn actual fat you'll lose some water
weight but you're gonna start burning
fat and the less carbohydrates that you
consume the more you're gonna get into
this fat burning your hunger is going to
go away
you're not going to crave anymore these
two things alone will allow you to stick
to it long term if you don't have hunger
and you don't have cravings and you
don't have low blood sugar issues it's
not going to be painful in fact you're
gonna find that your energy is going to
increase now there is an actual
adaptation phase two to three days it
takes your cells to adapt to fat-burning
so if you take enough electrolytes and B
vitamins you won't have any transitional
symptoms but you'll get into it your
your energy will spike your cognitive
function your focus your memory will do
better why because your brain loves
ketones you're gonna find inflammation
going down if you have stiffness or pain
in your body that's going to come down
your skin's gonna look better less acne
so I just want to make one little
distinction you have ketosis and then
you have healthy ketosis let me tell you
the difference healthy ketosis is
basically doing this low-carb plan with
very healthy ingredients in
nutrient-dense foods because one thing
about the ketogenic diet they don't
really tell you exactly the quality of
food that you should eat so I'm just
recommending make sure you do it healthy
for several reasons number one as you
lose weight you're gonna look better
okay you're gonna feel better and you're
gonna be healthier but the fact that
you're doing keto alone by lowering the
carbohydrates has huge benefits okay so
in the next part let me show you why so
the whole purpose of getting into
ketosis and running an alternative fuel
source is to drop and normalize your
insulin levels
nearly 80% of the population has a
problem with insulin they have a
condition called insulin resistance
where your receptors will not absorb
insulin like they normally should that
gives you dysfunctional insulin and the
body then has to make more and more
insulin to compensate and with that
comes a lot of health problems so you
have increased carbs lead to higher
amounts of insulin which then causes the
resistance because the body is being
bombarded by so much volume of insulin
it starts to shut down an average person
who has insulin resistance which by the
way this is pre-diabetes
makes between five to seven times more
insulin than normal so that massive
amounts of insulin leads to diabetes
metabolic syndrome which is a
combination of belly fat blood sugar
problems cholesterol problems people
with Alzheimer's have high amounts of
insulin they have insulin resistance and
then we have problems of the heart
simply because the inside layer of the
arteries are very susceptible to
oxidation and having high amounts of
insulin basically rust out your arteries
the body comes in forms plaquing
clotting calcium deposits to the point
where you can get heart attacks and even
a struggle and then Harding of the
arteries that comes from high amounts of
insulin insulin resistance is connected
to mood disorders anxiety depression you
eventually get a fatty liver and also
cancer because cancer cells basically
live on sugar so now let me show you
specifically what to eat so let me give
you a rough idea of what you would
actually eat on a healthy ketogenic plan
okay now as far as calories go we take a
look at this pie chart carbohydrates are
basically five percent of the total
calories I'm adding vegetables
separately that aren't included in the
carbs in fact I don't want you to count
the vegetable carbohydrate for two
reasons number one there's not a lot of
calories in the veggies number one
number two we want to encourage more
vegetables and so anytime we're talking
about cutting carbs we don't want you to
cut
your vegetables okay and vegetables have
a very low glycemic reaction they don't
spike your blood sugars and they do not
increase insulin very much and also
realize that the fiber in the vegetable
and vegetables are very fiber rich even
though their carbohydrates they don't
trigger the insulin response so our
veggies will be around 5% of the total
calories which is about seven plus cups
per day seven to ten cups per day and
then pro team should be 20% of the total
calories that's basically 3 to 6 ounces
per meal now if you have a bigger person
have more okay so this is just an arm
range this is a moderate amount of
protein and when I talk about 3 to 6
ounces of protein I'm not talking about
the protein in the product like the meat
or fish I'm talking about the actual
meat or fish by itself if you were to
weigh the whole thing because let's say
for example in fish you have collagen
you have other things other than the
protein so 3 ounces of fish versus 3
ounces of protein and fish is a
different value we're talking about the
actual whole food itself when I talk
about 3 to 6 ounces and then we want
about 70% of fat now this seems like a
lot of fat doesn't it well let's take a
look at an actual plate let's say this
is your plate you divide it in down the
center and you have the plate you add
vegetables ok or salad then 1/4 of the
plate will be your protein and 1/4 would
be your fat so as you can see this 70%
of fat seems like a lot is not as much
as you think
simply because fat has more calories per
volume so this is about calories okay
this is about volume of food and then of
course over here we have our small
amount of carbs okay all right so just
let me give you some rough ideas and
what we're talking about when we talk
about carbs we're not talking about
breads or pasta or Sarah or crackers or
juice we're talking about the carbs and
nuts and seeds now nuts and seeds have
protein okay they have fat but
they have some carbs so those are the
carbs you're counting hummus it has low
sugar but it has some carbs but hummus
also is made with olive oil and garlic
so there's fat in the olive oil and then
berries are very low on the glycemic
index but you would count the carbs in
berries and then protein right here we
have meats we have fish we have seafood
we have eggs we have cheese but of
course meat and fish eggs and cheese
also have fat so when you're dealing
with the most foods you're having a
combination of things
so this basically half of this is could
be a combination of some food with that
and protein you're not going to eat them
separately here's some examples of pure
fat butter coconut oil avocado but see
avocado has fat and some carbs then you
have olive oil which is a pure fat and
then as far as the veggies go you have
leafy greens and you have cruciferous
and there's other vegetables so I
recommend most of the vegetables you
consume leafy greens as salads consume
them raw but if you're gonna add
cruciferous I would recommend steamed
them or cook them unless you're doing
like a kale shake with some berries
that's totally fine so ideally you want
to go 7 and 10 cups with your vegetables
per day now that might seem like a lot
but that provides a lot of nutrients a
lot of antioxidants a lot of vitamins
and minerals and of course the
cruciferous not only has higher amounts
of vitamins and minerals that has high
amounts of phytonutrients which give you
additional health benefits all right one
more section on what not to eat all
right so let's just talk about what not
to eat so we want to avoid grains okay
in the form of whole grains and refined
grains breads pasta cereal crackers
biscuits waffles pancakes even though
something is gluten-free
it still has grains so just to avoid all
grains rice okay avoid that then we have
starches potatoes okay now rice is also
starch as well so avoid potatoes yams
sweet potatoes
rice anything starchy avoided why
because they're gonna turn into sugar
really fast and then we have actual
sugar we have cane sugar we have a
goblin nectar there you have honey you
have fructose high fructose corn syrup
you're gonna to avoid all sugars now you
can do alternative sugars like stevia
monk fruit xylitol or wreath root all
these are sugar alcohols they have a
much lower reaction on the glycemic
index than regular sugar all right and
so you want to avoid GMO foods okay that
would be soy oil corn oil canola if you
consume organic you're pretty safe with
GMO and of course juice is a sugar you
want to avoid that and you want to avoid
soda
there are sodas out there now that are
flavored with stevia those are
acceptable but juice is loaded with way
too much sugar okay so as far as fish
goes very important don't consume the
farm fed do wild-caught much much
healthier I have many videos on that you
can do a search on that if you want to
know why pasture-raised organic eggs are
the best they're a little bit more
expensive but they are worth it and then
we have Organic bacon okay that way
you know that the pigs are not fed the
GMO grains we want to avoid that and
I'll try to get the bacon that's sugar
free and nitrate free so if you're
consuming cheese or cream or
half-and-half or butter from grass-fed
cows it's definitely a lot better now if
you're gonna do coffee really try to get
organic because coffee is one of the
crops that's the most heavily sprayed of
any crops out there okay guys there you
have it I have a really cool download
below if you want to get a summary sheet
of all the foods on a healthy ketogenic
plan click down below and download it
and that way you have it on a couple
pieces of paper and you can refer back
to it thanks for watching
if you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos